What's the matter, miss?
You look like you might have an inkling.
I don't.
No need to get cross.
Just leave me be.
You'll be in Neo Xianglong for a while,
right?
We're still looking for new recruits.
You'll get no royal treatment,
but the pay is good.
It's not money I'm after.
Looks like we got rejected, commander.
Not to worry. I've still got hope.
Well, power to you.
Doesn't matter to me though.
An attack from above?
It wasn't a missile strike?
Analysis of the
transport plane's logs revealed
that it was attacked at 12,000 meters.
That's far beyond the range
of any anti-aircraft missile.
Hey, Leon. Why don't you hold off
on the mahua for a while?
He's always been like that,
snacking during class all the time.
So, what are you saying?
The attacker was most likely...
a giant flying BRAI.
Giant?
So, a birdie?
Normally, there's a limit to the weight
of flying animals.
An aerial BRAI large enough
to tear apart a transport plane
defies the laws of physics.
Could it have one of those
Dark Drives in it?
If so, it could be amplifying its lift by
dispersing it across multiple dimensions.
Their evolution is far beyond
what we imagined.
It's called the absolute-defense system,
but it's weak against attacks from above.
I've said it before,
but your budget priorities are crazy.
-Shouldn't measures be--
-You don't need to say it.
Be prepared just in case it happens.
They just keep coming.
It never seems to stop.
It's been a few years since
the BRAI appeared.
Due to the evolutionary fields,
they've evolved at an astounding pace.
It's as if they've undergone
several billion years of evolution
all in a single bound.
Only humans have been left behind.
Even if that's so, we still have to live.
They're the ones that must be culled.